[Música]
ah
señoras señores niños y público en
general qué pasa con el teatro hecho en
el mundo rural yo digo que hay mil
teatros mil maneras de jugar pues hay
mil mundos en este y el teatro es un
lugar que dialoga con su entorno es su
esencia el dialogar y no es lo mismo que
uno cada día al despertar observé coches
y atascos grandes montañas con nieve o
las basuras del mar hoy aquí por resumir
contrastó dos ideales un teatro de
ciudad frente al de entornos rurales si
el teatro es un espejo de los conflictos
sociales si además de divertirnos nos
habla de nuestros males porque habla de
nosotros con dialógica verdad porque
tanto nos inspira un teatro de ciudad
porque tanto nos influye porque tanto
nos impone porque tanto de admirar a un
teatro que me excluye
pero dejemos aquí esta previa
introducción comience ya la verdad que
comience la función y para hablar de
teatro el coloquio es mi manera a un
lado cualquier ciudad y al otro un
pueblo cualquiera
el teatro ha estado tradicionalmente
ubicado en el centro de las ciudades
porque el mismo teatro es un centro un
ágora una plaza un claro en el bosque de
cemento el teatro ha de estar mirando la
cara a los cabildos y los juzgados de
los palacios los bulevares los cafés
mirándole la cara o las caras las
múltiples caras a la sociedad y
sintiendo su flujo influjo y reflujo y
ser el desagüe el crisol de todas sus
pasiones y sus contradicciones un
paquete de espejos siempre deformados
que diría valle inclán la caja pandora
de la sociedad
la caja de los conflictos la caja
escénica
en esto somos iguales el teatro se ha
hecho siempre en el centro de los
pueblos donde se ponen también los
mercados y las ferias nos va a poner en
las huertas donde no va nadie pero
nuestro conflicto no es aristocrático
nada sabemos de desfiles de la moda de
parís o que canta la gran vía' la ciudad
sigue siendo aristocrática a la antigua
usanza levantando sus fronteras
ideológicas frente al pueblo o plebe o
populacho y diciéndonos que es de gusto
y que es de mal gusto juan manuel es
garcilaso so be llenas la creación desde
arriba utilizándome a mí al pueblo para
fingir me para idealizar me o como haro
tecglen decía de maria antonieta antes
de ser guillotinada
para jugar a las pastoras
esta creación desde arriba esta
imposición del gusto este despotismo
ilustrado o no ilustrado es transversal
en la historia un paquete de espejos
deformados a posta y que no tienen
ninguna intención de reflejar nos sólo
es un reflejo de una cosa del poder del
poder cultural que no sólo es poder sino
que es el máximo poder
la cultura el primer poder no me haga
reír les unan de algo los poderes
legislativo ejecutivo y judicial
esos son conceptos
esos son conceptos y como conceptos son
culturales por eso cambian tanto de un
lugar a otro y de un momento a otro las
leyes son culturales los sistemas
políticos son culturales el sentido de
justicia es cultural la cultura es lo
que articula todo esto y lo pone en
práctica por esto quien pueda controlar
la cultura tendrá el mayor poder es la
hegemonía cultural de gran sí o la
violencia simbólica devolución por
ejemplo es cultural que en unos países y
no en otros tengamos una monarquía es
cultural también que no se nos pase por
la cabeza guillotinar los
en realidad es cultural todo lo que se
nos pasa por la cabeza porque cultural
es toda mirada sobre el mundo
entonces es cultural la mirada que tengo
de ti por supuesto y la mirada que yo
tengo de ti que es regala la vida la que
huye del mundo and al ruido ja happ de
regala está nada en el campo se trabaja
y mucho entonces es cultural la mirada
que tengo del campo toda mirada es
cultural hasta la mirada de un amanecer
o de la nieve es cultural porque cultura
es transmisión y condicionamiento por
esto como se suele decir y como se suele
poner de ejemplo en fin es hay 40
palabras para designar la nieve
nosotros no tenemos tantas no las
necesitamos no niego a tanto
también por esto desaparecen palabras de
camps o ac milan a bañar marranero hola
martín gada no solo porque porque haya
profesiones o herramientas en desuso
sino porque todos hablamos como oímos y
por ende terminamos hablando cómo se
habla en televisión y la televisión es
tuya por supuesto yo la ciudad tengo el
trabajo el dinero y la población tengo
los museos y los teatros
tengo claro la televisión y tengo la
prensa tengo por tanto el poder y la
influencia tengo las riendas de la
cultura el progreso de la cultura y a mí
me dejas una cultura menor y sobre todo
arqueológica una cultura de la
inmovilidad cuando la cultura es siempre
por definición contemporánea una cultura
relegada bajo la etiqueta folclore pero
te diré una cosa cuanto más me alejo de
ti de tu influencia del poder en
definitiva más me convierto en cultura
alternativa
y esa etiqueta si la conoces si la usas
soy el coro de las ratas de tu zarzuela
la gran vía que tanto gustaba noche que
yo también tengo cultura alternativa
porque yo tengo de todo pero de qué te
quejas yo tengo el pensamiento y te lo
llevo
y piensa sobre unas cosas y yo sobre
otras pensamos con lo que vemos recuerda
lo de la nieve tú piensas - la nieve
porque la tienes menos tiempo más
controlada y menos molesta tú no piensas
sobre el calendario de siembra sobre el
estado de los caminos sus creadores es
lógico como seres urbanos pues tampoco
piensan sobre un montón de cosas que
piensa la gente de campo porque piensan
sobre lo que les rodea
no conozco ninguna obra de teatro
ninguna cuyo tema sea el estado precario
del acceso a algunos pueblos tampoco del
conflicto entre ecología y explotación
como sucede entre la repoblación de
lobos y la ecología libre y ecológico y
la ganadería libre y ecológica tampoco
del conflicto entre la industria del
cerdo y la alta contaminación de sus
purines tampoco de lo que se conoce como
el impuesto al sol del problema a escala
mundial de las semillas transgénicas
solamente encontrado una obra de teatro
de una compañía chilena
por tenernos al teatro
el arte del conflicto por antonomasia no
hay obras de teatro sobre estos temas
sin embargo de estos problemas y de
otros muchos podría hablar largo y
tendido la gente de campo y no es porque
a ti no te afecten porque te afectan
entonces a qué se debe vamos a ver se
debe a que las obras que hacen tus
creadores hablan de tus cosas y las
obras que hacen los míos porque yo tengo
los míos también hablan de tus cosas se
ven reflejados en ti reproducen tus
moldes
fuera porque quieren quizás porque
quieren quizás no se den cuenta el
imperialismo cultural es tremendamente
fuerte en ocasiones incluso es
intencionado al igual que se hace con la
información periodística el teatro
también sufre un intrusismo controlador
por parte de los poderes se ejerce
indirectamente a través de los filtros
administrativos a la hora de adjudicar
las ayudas y subvenciones económicas a
través de las elecciones para los
canales de distribución y solamente en
última instancia por la censura directa
pensar lo contrario sería pecar de
inocentes la clase de inocencia que le
hace el juego el poder
aunque repito ahora quiero insistir en
la influencia no consciente en la
enculturación que tenemos asumida
sí hasta creo rastrearla en el estilo o
en el estilo en los rasgos formales de
una obra de teatro ves tú mi influencia
yo no te digo si tienes que vestirte de
azul o de rojo no te digo como tienes
que andar sobre la escena
el teatro siempre ha sido paradigmático
el público iba iba al teatro a ver cómo
andaba y anda el galán con qué porte y
elegancia se sienta la dama de ahí los
vivos y las divas quienes marcaban la
moda de lo que se consideraba elegancia
y que la sociedad en su conjunto trataba
de imitar
los tiempos de las divas ya han pasado
diría mejor que aquel tipo de elegancia
ha pasado de moda todavía hoy como diría
oscar wilde
la vida sigue imitando el arte por lo
que prefieras en todo caso sucedía
porque eres muy influenciable no más que
tú te ves o no te des cuenta además
sigue sucediendo porque toda la cultura
se construye sobre los modelos que
conocemos tener más cultura significa
tener más modelos simplemente y esto
pretexto está uniformando nuestros
modelos hay mil hay miles de obras de
teatro de todo tipo
y es cierto pero te diré que hoy día una
de las categorías supremas de crítica es
la limpieza de una obra de teatro
esto significa que sus movimientos sean
limpios precisos perfectamente
controlados también hay una manera de
decir los textos por no hablar de los
condicionantes del mercado esto es
influencia tuya piramidal vivimos la
supremacía del teatro de consumo muy
bien hecho muy atractivo pero ajeno en
un par de días olvidado o estás
generalizando estoy generalizando y
mucho pero es que ahora la vida se nos
pasa en general yo a menudo llamo
burgués a tu teatro ese teatro de
emociones en general y de ideas en
general a menudo ni siquiera nos
divierte de verdad solamente nos
entretiene y por eso una vez más debemos
recordar estas famosas palabras de
federico garcía lorca
un pueblo que no ayuda y no fomenta su
teatro si no está muerto está moribundo
como el teatro que no recoge el latido
social el latido histórico de el drama
de sus gentes y el color genuino de sus
paisajes y de sus y de sus espíritus con
risa o con lágrimas no merece llamarse
teatro sino sala de juego o sitio para
hacer esa horrible cosa que se llama
matar el tiempo
estoy defendiendo exactamente esto el
teatro hecho en el mundo rural por su
descentralización por su independencia
quizás por su intrascendencia tiene una
mayor capacidad de libertad de encontrar
ese latido histórico y al menos hay que
ayudarle a que encuentre su sitio su
realidad
su verdad
esta charla no pretende ser una ley no
pretende ser algo taxonómico ni siquiera
es una certeza es simplemente una pauta
de reflexión una llamada de atención una
provocación a quien pues a señoras
señores niños y público en general
difícil y ardua tarea para un creador
rural es luchar contra marea sin su
público local así que vayan a verle que
si no van a perder lo que ha de ganarse
el pan es verdad que toda lucha necesita
de su lucha
dijo
luz en la taquilla
cuenta calderilla
en la ventanilla manos de hospital
iba a ser el enjambre
y dio en el alambre la sombra del hambre
[Música]
ah